Lord hints that she's not in Taylor
Swift's squad I don't hang out with
[Music]
in an interview with australia's sunrise
morning show that aired on friday the
greenlight singer was asked how she
copes with the friending some of the
people she idolized like Beyonce and
Taylor Swift the thickening things too
hot about it you just go insane so it
speaks to me like we're in Wonderland
that's just what happens around here
then the 20 year old dropped this bomb I
don't hang out with these people at all
like a depending on if you're hired by a
squad I mean all the magazine must tell
I you know you make friends in different
places but I think for the most part
like oh you know I'm not like calling up
my idols for advice necessarily that
headshake says it all
in June Lord compared her friendship
with the a-list singer to an autoimmune
disease during an interview with The
Guardian quote it's like having a friend
with very specific allergy there are
certain places you can't go together
certain things you can't do she later
apologized on Twitter as for Taylor she
supported Lord on Instagram in March
telling fans to check out her pals new
single
[Music]
[Applause]